محمد المغير مدير الامداد بالدفاع المدني
في قطاع غزه اهلا بك معنا ربما ابدا معك
مما رصده الدفاع المدني في بيت
لاهيه من انتشال جثث اعدمت ميدانيا
ونهشت الكلاب ما المعلومات المتوفره
لديكم
حسب اسعد الله مساءكم ومساء الساده
المستمعين حسب افاده الدفاع المدني والتي
ما زالت تعمل في م منطقه شمال غزه في هذه
اللحظات اي
طواقمنا وال المواطنين يتعرضون لقصف عنيف
في محيط منطقه جبالي البلد حيث تحاول قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دخول منطقه وسط بلد
جبالي من محاور متعدده اما في المناطق
التي تراجع الاحتلال منها تقدمت طواقم
الدفاع المدني
برفقه مقدمي خدمات الاسعاف والطوارئ ووجدت
العديد من الجثت المتحلله والتي
تم هجوم الكلاب الضاله عليها واكل جزء
منها وهذا
يعتبر مشاهد
اليمه يشاهدها طواقم الدفاع المدني وتساهم
في الضغط النفسي الزائد عليهم كذلك ما
زالت طواقمنا الان تعمل مع باقي مقدمين
خدمات الاستجابه لرفع اكبر قدر ممكن من
الاعدامات الميدانيه التي وجدت في بعض
المدارس بعض اماكن النزوح التي كانت
الاحتلال متوغل فيها وما زال حصر الوفيات
والاعداد من الطواقم مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه
المشاهد هي ماساويه
اي تعبر عن قلق بالغ من قبل الطواقم خاصه
ان المناطق التي تقدمت فيها طواقم الدفاع
المد هي
مناطق كان الاحتلال متوغل بها وفيها
العديد من التجريف حتى في البنيه التحتيه
اثناء تحرك التواق الدفاع المدني وجد
صعوبه بالغه لان اثار الطرقات والشوارع
تغير في سبب عمليه التجريف هل يمنع الجانب
الاسرائيلي طواقم الاسعاف ورجال الدفاع
المدني حتى مع التنسيق مع مع ال الهيئات
الامميه في الدخول و يعني انتشال الجثث
على الاقل انلا تبقى هذه الجثث حتى تتحلل
و تنهشها الكلى التنسيق التنسيق هو عباره
عن اكذوبه كبيره جدا عندما يتم التنسيق
يتم استهدافنا بشكل مباشر ونحن نفكر بشكل
جدي الان تدرس قياده الدفاع المدني قطع
علاقاتها مع المنظمات ذات العلاقه التي تج
عمليه التنسيق ويستهدف طواقم الدفاع
المدني اثناء التنسيق اي في عمليه التنسيق
اللي بتتم اي غالبا غالبا يتم استهداف
الطواقم منح من الدخول في المرات السابقه
والسنوات الماضيه كانت طواقم الدفاع من
ترفضها مركبه الصليب اثناء عمليه الدخول
للمناطق العملي العسكريه لكن في هذه المره
الصليب الاحمر انسحب من مناطق العمليات
العسكريه وهذا يعتبر مخالف لان مناطق
النشاط العمل الصليب الاحمر في مناطق
النزاعات والصراعات مش في المناطق اللي
المناطق الامنه التي حددها الدول المحتله
وهذه من النقاط التي رصدتها ميه العام
الدفاع الم ضد اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر وسيكون خلال الايام القادمه اخذ
موقف جدي من هذا الموضوع فيما يتعلق
بالطواقم التي تحاول الوصول في جباليه تم
استهداف طواقمنا بطائرات الاستطلاع ثلاث
مرات طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم الانقاذ اثناء
تقدمهم لانقاذ الارواح في منطقه جبالي
البلد في ح وهم الان يحاولون التوغل من
خمس محاور الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كذلك الحال
في منطقه شرق نادي البريج في منطقه البريج
يحاول طواقمنا الدخول واخراج العالقين
والنازحين ونداءات الاستغاثه كبيره جدا
لكن لم يستطيعوا الدخول بسبب اطلاق
القذائف من المدفعيه او الاستطلاع اللي
بيتم ضربه بين الحين والاخر طبيعه عملنا
في كل الازمات والكوارث هو العمل تحت
الخطر وتحت الضغط وهذا يعرض حياتنا وحياه
منتسبينا الى الخطر الداهم والى فقدان
الارواح وفقدان طواقم الدفاع المدني مع
العلم ان القانون الدولي الانساني يلزم
الدول المحتله بضروره العمل على حمايه هذه
الطواقم لان هم ممين بفعل القانون الدولي
الانساني فيما يتعلق ايضا بما يقول جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بانه يدفع السكان
الانتقال من منطقه الى اخرى دير البلاح من
المناطق التي دعى فيها سكان الانتقال
اليها ثم استهدفت اليوم وسط القطاع وهناك
جريح وايضا شهيد في تلك المنطقه